Speaker 1: It appears as though Donald Trump
was notified by his lawyers yesterday after
their meeting with the Justice Department
that he will almost certainly be getting arrested
and charged federally.
Donald Trump immediately took to his social
media platform Truth, social.
Speaker 2: Truth Central.
Speaker 1: Where he ranted about how other
Presidents.
Speaker 2: Obama.
Speaker 1: Now haven't been arrested or indicted.
You did.
I guess for the crimes Trump may have committed,
you've got to see this mostly with caps lock
engaged.
Donald Trump posting after his lawyers gave
him the bad news quote, How can DOJ possibly
charge me who did nothing wrong when no other
presidents were charged?
There's an apostrophe on presidents.
We don't know why.
It's a myth.
It that's a totally woke apostrophe.
We're not going to do the woke grammar in
Florida, where if you do the apostrophe when
you actually don't mean possessive, you mean
plural.
We're just not going to do it.
Teachers won't be allowed.
Will will fire them right away.
Okay.
When no other presidents were charged, when
Joe Biden won't be charged for anything, including
the fact that he has 850 boxes, much of it
classified and some dating back to his Senate
day when even Democrat senators are shocked.
Also, President Clinton had documents and
won in court.
Crooked Hillary deleted 33,000 emails, many
classified and wasn't even close to being
charged.
Only Trump the greatest witch hunt of all
time.
So Trump furious that other presidents haven't
been charged.
For the crimes Trump committed.
Okay.
This morning getting even more bonkers on
troth tro thing out a lot of agit trash, including
quote the marxists and fascists and the DOJ
and FBI are going after me at a level and
speed never seen before in our capital C country
and I did nothing wrong.
First question can we identify a single FBI
Marxist after years of talking about it?
Do we know of a single Marxist in the DOJ?
Trump continuing.
Joe Biden kept keeps thousands of documents
in many locations, some illegally taken from
skiffs while he was a senator, a big portion
of which were classified.
He didn't want to give them back and still
doesn't.
Nothing happens to him.
Would same reasonable prosecutor who correctly
exonerated Mike Pence?
I have a much different prosecutor, a Trump
hater than Trump going in the direction of
saying it's all about impacting Trump's 24
run, saying, quote, It's all about election
interference.
They don't want to run against me.
I ran twice.
I did much better the second time, getting
millions and millions more votes than the
first.
A record for a sitting president.
And I'm leading Biden in the polls by a lot.
They are the capital P party of Capital D
disinformation.
They are using the DOJ and FBI against me
to Capital R double g rig.
That's a doozy.
Capital R double G rig, the 2024 election.
They'll hit Hunter with something small to
make their strike on me look fair.
Nothing about these capital F fascists is
fair or honest fight.
These things are almost impossible to read.
And then lastly.
As of an hour ago, although he probably has
posted more, quote, They are also going after
me as retribution for the Republicans in Congress
going after them.
The difference is they have created major
crimes.
I have created none.
Now, for many of you wondering, did we get
to the bottom of Obama gate, the biggest political
crime of the century, as Trump once said?
No, we still don't know what Obama gate is.
And so the questions about why Clinton or
Obama or Hunter or whoever haven't been charged,
it appears as though at this time there is
not evidence of criminality.
Period.
That would be the reason.
Trump melting down on troth Essential.
We can only hope that justice is done.
Did people hear that?
Notice how I'm not saying I hope Trump is
thrown in prison and they throw away the key,
blah, blah, blah.
What I'm saying is I hope that if the evidence
points to criminality.
Justice is done.
That's called law and order.
Okay.
Not like this person up.
Despite no evidence of criminality.
Not lock that person up or kill people.
Execute people.
Even absent a guilty verdict.
No, it is.
I hope that there if there is evidence, nobody
is above the law.
All of these posts from troth will be on our
Instagram.
They will be on Tik Tok and they will certainly
be on Facebook.
That I promise you.